Speaker 1: Listen, we have
a problem in this country.
The problem we are told by you probably knew that
the problem we are being told by everybody from
neo-Nazis to white lives matter people to the
proud Boys, to all sorts of other unaffiliated
right wing activists, is that the problem is
drag shows, drag queens, drag time, story hours
and that sort of thing. Now, I have video to play
for you today of an event at a drag show at a
public park in Wadsworth, Ohio. I have video here
from Ford Fisher, from news to share. And what you
will see is that those who are against the drag
show and decided to protest are pretty horrible
people, including gun toting neo-Nazis, which you
will see the Patriot front, white lives matter,
so on and so forth. These are the folks
who are really, really upset that children,
if their parents choose to, might be brought
to a drag show. Take a look at this time.
Speaker 2: Go, go, go.
Speaker 1: Go.
So, by the way, there's a guy with a gun and a
swastika flag. Right on. If you're listening right
now, that's the first thing we're seeing here. And
of course, this is you know, as a parent myself,
if you say to me, what am I most interested
in keeping my daughter away from drag time,
story hour or gun toting neo-Nazis with swastikas?
The answer is pretty clear to me, my friends.
Speaker 2: And oh my gosh, I have.
Speaker 1:
Zig Hill is where we are right now.
Speaker 2: Oh,
what a basket, though. Why my condition?
Speaker 1: Why are you yelling? Pedophiles,
get something.
Speaker 2: Wow.
Speaker 1: Okay, that's probably enough.
Now, as you can tell, these are merely
people expressing economic anxiety because
of a middle class that has been left behind.
Right. Right. No, this really does this really
does go to show that this is not about all of
the innocent things that many on the Republican
right have started to say, that they very often
will say, you know, these right wing movements,
they are here because the Democratic Party has
left the middle class behind and they're suffering
economic anxiety and they're worried about jobs
being offshored to China and Mexican immigrants
documented or undocumented, taking their jobs
or whatever the case may be. This is not about
any of that. This is about retrograde, outdated,
hysterically backwards beliefs and the desire to
bring those beliefs into public into public view,
partially as a result of the normalization of
this type of stuff, dating back most acutely to
the Trump presidency. Now, I know I've said it
before, I don't believe Trump created racism.
I don't believe Trump created white supremacy
or neo-Nazi ism. Of course he didn't. But what
Trump did do is he made a lot of the people who
already believe those things more comfortable
espousing those views in public. And when you look
at CPAC today, when you looked at CPAC last year
and we noticed the biggest applause lines were the
transphobic stuff and the homophobic stuff and the
Marxists, there's Marxists, which of course, there
are very few Marxists in the United States. That
is part of the coddling of these sorts of views
where people end up being comfortable coming out
now. A lot of these people clearly aren't that
comfortable because they're wearing masks. And
if they were really confident and comfortable in
espousing these beliefs publicly, they wouldn't
wear the masks. And of course, I'm sure many of
them would end up getting themselves fired. But
that's not the situation. And again, just just
remember that at the core of this is drag shows
which parents might choose to bring their kids
to or maybe not, but we're talking about parental
choice, parental rights, which is what these
right wing groups claim to be all about. Well, let
parents make their choices then. Don't shut down
the drag event. Allow parents who like it to bring
their kids and allow parents who don't like it to
bring their kids somewhere else. But now, all of
a sudden, that freedom to parent goes away when
they decide we're going to show up with the guns
and with the swastikas in order to try to shut
this thing down. If you're just listening today,
the clip I played will be on our YouTube channel,
on our Facebook page, on our Instagram. You can
find it there. Make sure you are. Subscribe to
the YouTube channel and make sure you have liked
this video if you are watching on YouTube.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.